Katy Perry is for sure living her
teenage team you guys coming in hot the
singer topped the Forbes list of the
highest-paid women in music making a
measly 83 million dollars in a single
year is it silly if I make a joke that
her wallet is a firework her so uh you
guys Katy Perry uh topping it with 83
million dollars like we just said
beating out Taylor Swift who brought in
80 million and then Beyonce who brought
in 60 million dollars but here's the
thing everyone's wondering like why she
is the highest-paid woman in music right
now and it all really focuses on the
dates of how this was chosen so
basically let's break it down Ric
example herbs his numbers were based
this is probably one of the most
important facts about this from June
2017 to June 2018 right so we know that
Idol and also witness came out in the
summer so it's just the timing of when
she dropped new music and also had new
new activity in her career shock setup
but so what does that mean for next year
though well okay so this is my
prediction for next year because Taylor
Swift's reputation tour and because
beyonce is on the run to tour weren't
really they didn't really fall in these
dates I have a funny feeling next year
Katy's gonna lose that number one spot
but you mentioned like the Idol you
mentioned the witness tour breaking
those down in just numbers alone you
know Katy Perry was reportedly making
over 20 million dollars for American
Idol and then the witnessed tour Forbes
said the concert grossed over a million
dollars per night so you have the tour
you have the American Idol contract you
also have you know Katy Perry's
endorsements she's a working girl raking
in the dough right there but this is
this is everything that Katie's always
wanted we actually have a clip of her
talking in 2015 about her dream being
the best in the business
take a look I always dreamt that I want
to be the best in my field I've always
dreamt that I hope that my message in my
music is understood and people connect
with it
so you know full disclosure I am a Katie
Katz and and you know witness reportedly
and for some wasn't received well you
know Katie had talked about stepping
back from music but it's really cool to
see that she is in this position I was
more shocked to be brutally honest
that she beat out Taylor but you have to
you have to take into consideration that
dave taylor sure trailers tour was May
2018 to literally today but yes
technically that those are the receipts
right but just in the conversation it's
like ooh zinger hey
[Music]
[Applause]